hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey you know
I have three friend shirts and they're
all in the washer no we were gonna film
this I was like we're all just hug all
your pops we're gonna watch from Miss
mojo I hadn't even heard of this channel
till we got this request top 10 funniest
Chandler moments on friends my favorite
show of all time I actually have tickets
for my lady Anna to go watch their
re-releasing like 10 episodes of friends
and the feeders that sounds weird to me
yeah still watch us sick Tom withers
laughter in the show and head around and
we're laughing at some like strange
sound even funnier yeah it comes a
topper watery across from man named
Andrew Nickerson so yeah let's watch
this these moments be any funnier
welcome to miss mojo committed delivery
how much that videos for this list we're
taking a look at the funniest moments
from Chandler Bing we're exploding
moments that made us happy cry liked the
proposal as well as moments that
involved many members of the group like
miss chanandler bomb I'm not great at
the advice can I interest you in a
sarcastic comment number 10 the Taylor
incident you're Taylor is a very bad man
when Chandler needs some clothing
alterations taken care of he naturally
asked the group for advice Joey has a
tailor that he's been seen for years so
Chandler decides to pay him a visit
he's traumatized upon his return however
since the tailor has taken advantage of
him well prison-style
Joey's tailor took advantage of me
[Music]
the whole thing is totally normal
asserting that's just how they measure
pants as raw sites with Chandler though
Joey makes a startling revelation
Ross we tell is that our tailor measures
pants prison their shop is par for the
course and sets the theme early in the
show for more hilariously unfortunate
incidents that will happen to him oh my
god number 9 the cheesecake I've got to
try this cheesecake there are some
natural pairings on this show from Joey
and Chandler to Monica and Rachel to
Ross and Marcel but one dude that
doesn't get a lot of screen time
together is Chandler and Rachel I'm full
and yet I know if I stop eating this
I'll regret it
this season seven episode has it's
wishing desperately that they had been
paired up more often because the
aftermath of them eating a series of
stolen cheese is just too good not the
Cheesecake cake they delivered it to the
wrong address again so just bring it
back to upstairs what's the problem I
can't seem to take a buck it shows both
of their most childish and ridiculous
sides with the two battling until the
bitter end over who will get more cake
for themselves
number 8 the shark porn
Who am I kidding pay-per-view porn the
period where Chandler is working halfway
across the country in Tulsa Oklahoma is
a tough one for his relationship with
Monica
when Monica decides to pay him a
surprise visit though things get even
worse do note mr. Chandler having some
personal time and when he panics to
change the channel he ends up landing on
a shark documentary well the weird part
is he was getting off to a short attack
show
yes Chandler watch a shark porn he
thinks he's in the clear but Monica
knows what her husband was doing and
therefore assumes that he was pleasuring
himself to the Sharks on screen like
every great sitcom joke this
misunderstanding makes for incredible TV
[Laughter]
you were doing in Tulsa angry sharks
turn you on no they don't number seven
Chandler can't catch this oh it's so
hard some of the best friends episodes
involved the characters sitting around
doing essentially nothing together and
this one is no exception
Joey and Ross have been absent mindedly
throwing a ball back and forth for a
while before they realize that hours
have passed without them dropping it
whatever you do do not drop that ball
yeah we haven't dropped to end
twenty-seven minutes when Monica gets
involved the casual game is
unsurprisingly escalated to a full-blown
competition but it's no surprise to
anyone that Chandler is the weak link
for hours you guys been doing this for
four hours that's right baby
all right he's a dropper the key moment
comes at the very end of the episode
when viewers are treated to a
compilation of Chandler dropping things
I'm anything but a dropper
number six when he takes a bath yes
we're all in here and we'd love for you
to join us
Chandler shows time and time again
throughout the show that he isn't
exactly secure in his masculinity oh
this isn't so bad I like the flower
smell which is okay because I've got
from a moat so it fits his character
perfectly that he would be reluctant to
get into the habit of taking baths fans
will remember that he willingly took a
romantic soap with Monica in season five
when they first started dating but it
takes until season eight for him to want
to bathe solo when you get help maybe I
can give you official I'm gonna need a
bigger boat this funny plotline ends
with a poignant moment when as the
friends are gathered around Chandler in
the tub Ross and Rachel revealed the sex
of their baby of course it's Chandler
and his boat that ultimately steal the
show we're having a girl flashbacks are
used sparingly but effectively on
friends giving viewers a glimpse into
the past and revealing previously
unknown information about our favorite
scenes are not as funny stuck here all
night with your fat sister we also get
to see the disastrous beginnings of
Monica and Chandler's relationship with
Monica wanting to get revenge on
Chandler after he called her fat and
accidentally cutting his toe off in the
process
right
[Music]
[Applause]
number four yes we used to be on the
list
I hope in this video pens we're still
getting to know the care homes and this
iconic episode cemented just how
hilarious Chandler can be when New York
experience is a citywide blackout
Chandler gets stuck in an ATM vestibule
with Jill Goodacre a real-life
Victoria's Secret model would you like
to call somebody yeah 300 guys I went to
high school he panics given the
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and tries
calling Joey for advice resulting in a
hilarious exchange over the phone it
wasn't meant to be between Chandler and
Jill but at this point we knew that
Chandler's awkward sense of humor was
perfection you know what ii thought gum
would be perfection
number three advertising brainstorming
cheez-its milk that you chew drop is a
constant running joke on the show due to
the fact that none of his friends seem
to know exactly what it is that he does
when he decided that he needs to follow
his passions and then do something that
really matters to him he attempts to
enter the advertising industry but great
because who can get a watermelon in your
mouth while we know Chandler can come up
with a witty one-liner
his marketing skills leave something to
be desired the phone bring you closer to
people who have phones throughout the
episode he tries out advertising slogans
while practicing to impress a new
employer and each one is worse than the
last bagels and doughnuts round food for
every mood
mónica warned me you might do that Oh
Janice
[Applause]
did you know that Janus appears at least
once in every single season of friends
every time she does it means hilarity
will ensue where's the spin-off my great
reactions to her some of our favorite
moments are when he set up on a blind
date with her when he falls in love with
her online and of course when he has to
buy a plane ticket to Yemen just to get
out of dating her again I guess I'm
going to Yemen are you even in the
show's final episodes this relationship
manages to get big laughs as Monica and
Chandler have to devise a plan to ensure
that they don't end up living beside
Janice in their new home I need you I
must have you Janice Littman growl
McMahons Dean before we avail our top
pick here are a few honorable mentions
oh you go I've scared you I've said too
much
I'm hopeless and awkward and desperate
to love I'm gonna say this for the last
time would you please just what's that
[ __ ] that's my nubbin number-one BB
versus Chandler
lassic I'm very happy we're gonna have
all the sex and what's easily one of the
best friends episodes everyone in the
group finally finds out about Monica and
Chandler's romantic relationship
before this happens though the series of
events leads to Phoebe seducing Chandler
in an effort to call his bluff and get
him to admit that he's actually dating
Monica oh hello mr. bicep their exchange
is almost painfully funny with neither
willing to back down first and the
situation escalating further and further
the end result is not only funny but
touching too with Chandler finally
exclaiming that he loves Monica do you
agree with our picks check out these
other Greeks I love them for new videos
every day
alright man so how to Miss mojo fare
against WatchMojo heard a voice many
times totally different ranking system
different algorithms when I was a kid
the first season Phoebe's dating a
therapist the therapist tells Chandler
basically give us a basic psychoanalysis
breakdown of him that he blocks pain
with humor
I immediately know Don and how it's like
I'm gonna do that too headaches
conscious no to do that Chandler's them
these muff favors mostly there's a lot
of people's favorite he's a good role
model
yeah he's everyone should aspire to be
that's a good point they made about how
Chandler and Rachel actually don't
really have too much of their own
dynamics together I know there was I
think it was season three was one of the
early flashback episodes where a 1-point
Rachel does fantasize about Chandler and
then Matthew Perry and Jennifer Aniston
like make out for a second but it's in
this fantasy it's not it's not real yeah
but that now that I think about it they
don't really have a lot of one-on-one
time together there's actually a really
solid point that you made about that
another moment that could have been now
there's the episode where it's one of
his post Janice breakups and if they're
playing football on Thanksgiving and
Joey and Chandler are competing - let's
hope I'm editing this video so it's
easier to find although Chandler are
competing for this chick from the
Netherlands there's this one great
moment that's not like a lot of these to
work if you don't have the whole scene
I'm sitting here throughout this video
going oh I saw this episode I did not
see this episode thanks let me have her
pretty taps Joey on the shoulder or
Joey's like yeah you know you're good at
math and Stephanie you guys like math
you're giving me math it's not funny
without any context but it always makes
me laugh the way math you're giving me
math he has a very special grip on
delivery especially I mean like I guess
in the later seasons you can kind of
feel him playing the character more but
those like quips and one-liners it's so
hard to sell that at the right level and
yes so good at it yeah there's a very
specific type of sarcasm that I think a
lot of people have taken on because it's
like heightened but it but he's natural
about it it's weird his sarcasm
obviously stems from a repression format
and I think that's what makes his
character so appealing is that he's just
so uncomfortable dealing with like real
emotions yes everything becomes humorous
and I think that's where so much of his
types of antics come from and Matthew
Perry attends them for most of his
comedy roles Annette yeah was it the
pitch meeting where he points out that
nobody on the show actually laughs at
Chandler's show yes Chandler's like the
wisecracking sarcastic guy of the group
so he's always making the other friends
laugh they will never laugh at his jokes
never never
so he's like cracking the jokes for
himself I guess I guess isn't that a
little crazy it is when you stop to
think about it that has always stuck
with me too and it's something that now
I always notice about the shows that
like he has the funniest moments but yet
nobody else in the cast yes you know
well there's some there's a moment
there's an episode where while he's they
talk about when he's living in Tulsa
Monica calls Chandler about how he has
his new coworker and she says he's the
funniest guy I've ever met any please
freaks out about it you will love him he
is without a doubt the funniest guy I
have ever met
I would have that exact fluid I don't
care to be the funniest person in the
world at all I would care to be a
funniest person in the room but in the
eyes of my girlfriend if I'm not funny
just person she destroyed the completely
annihilate me yes I really identify with
that I was really glad they put on that
moment from season one where he's stuck
in the bank with the model because
there's a lot there's that voiceover
they record it to it it also showcases
how funny he is the models not funny in
that mo but he's primarily just reacting
and doing a lot of body language type of
comedy more on the subtle approach as
cuz we know him for like is the way he's
funny with his physicality and we know
in one-liners rods day yeah but to be
funny would just primarily body language
I think is a testament to his abilities
and it did show is like awkward
sensibilities of how powerful that can
be so early on in this series the only
season I didn't really care for Matthew
Perry specifically was the 7 season he's
usually like a really skinny yeah yeah
and then he's opened up about how he's
had drug addiction problems and he says
that there's like a solid like three
seasons or something where he can't
really remember filming it and then the
sixth season ends with him for posing to
Monica and it's like I cry every time I
watch it so frozen Monica and he's
gained a lot of weight by that point out
I don't care then the seventh season
picks up it supposed to pick up on that
exact same night no and he somehow in
that summer break just lost all the
weight and he's oh the skinniest he's
ever looked awkwardly skinny and he had
like he literally watched that you've
watched those two episodes back-to-back
and he's it's a shame distracting weight
loss I don't know if it was around the
time he started getting a little bit
more clean sobered up so there was
something about the humor of how he was
doing it that was feeling a little bit
forced and played up as opposed to just
feeling natural the muscle memory is not
there I don't know what out of her
looking like the behind the scenes of
what happened there yeah that's just how
I felt watching it but then that pretty
much the first half of that whole season
kind of felt that way to me overall and
then but towards the end of the season
that's when he marries Manik
like he starts coming back and he's back
to being hilarious again Chan the
mansion and allure bonk Chandler Muriel
Bing Bing search engine that's here do
you have any any grapes I think them
over is hang tough this is a one that
should have been on the list that was a
beautiful visit here that's a Chandler
Rachel episode - okay I don't know
sleeping with her boss she wants to do
something naughty and handcuffs in there
yeah BDSM Chandler pretty much the first
most episodes of the first six of the
succeeds every Chandler movie yeah
what's your favorite Chandler moment
who's your favorite friends character
leave a comment down below who's your
favorite actor to play Chandler you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell Andrew thanks so
much for sending this over dude Andrew I
looked up your last name Nickerson a
short form version is that it derives
from a couple of names ultimately comes
down to which means to conquer oh man
dude that's strong you are a strong
presence you have conquered our hearts
you can go out there conquer all the
ladies in a you know in a completely
respectful consensual manner if you're
given permission to coat overpower rip
conker the flirting yeah yeah yeah I
know you want to get a house one day and
settle down again just don't well let me
change your last name take her name
because this can get really yeah don't
you're gonna get it so clearly this
we're trying to shine a light on just to
let you know I mean your last name
basically means conquer people and
that's alarming to most people how Boley
give them a new not last name get a
different get a different last name
manager Andrew Chandler Bing Andrew Bing